[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's up Prof hi Martin are you well
Welter no it's my turn okay sorry are
you well yes I am well and you I'm very
happy to hear
it oh wonderful uh it's just it's
actually a a blessing to do this these
discussions it's not easy always no but
um the Lord sustains us yes he's very
good to us this one is perhaps uh a
little bit
theological but it fits in with uh the
others that we have been
doing and it gives a little bit of the
background I don't think uh everybody
will be very cheered
necessarily but uh I believe that's the
way it is it is so let's open with a
word of prayer yes our heavenly father
once again we want to thank you that we
are in the position to do these
discussions and we've got the privilege
to do it we ask that you please
enlighten our minds guide our discussion
in Jesus name amen
amen we've titled it in the
sanctuary because everything that God
does is associated with the sanctuary
true yeah I mean the whole Old Testament
revolves around the
sanctuary and the modern world seems to
think you can just take a pair of
scissors cut that off and forget about
it uh we've got a new deal where
everything is honori do as thou please
seems to be the whole of the law so that
doesn't make any sense to just discard
2third of the Bible right true I mean
the sanctuary comes from heaven right
through the Bible and that's why yes
Revelation is full of it and then it's
very important to understand that the
Earthly is a copy of the Heavenly yeah
it's just a copy it's just a model it's
a
demonstration yeah it's an enacted
story uh it's a theater that's it and
those taking part in it are acting the
roles and uh down to the lamb which
isn't exactly crucified but pays the
price yeah yeah so all of these things
are in there and we mustn't forget that
the Earthly being a model for the
Heavenly uh tells us where Jesus is and
what he is doing and what his ministry
is all about currently yes because I
when we at the school I also asked the
students isn't it interesting before you
learn or or get taught this the
sanctuary you don't actually know know
anything about what is Jesus doing what
is currently where you don't even think
heaven is real actually no it's just a
yeah it's sort of nebulous then right
yeah it's but here is a very precise uh
job description if I can put it that way
but we're not going to discuss the
sanctuary per se and the message we're
going to discuss the importance of the
sanctuary Administration in terms of of
the stream of time and what the
implications are because then it becomes
uh a very serious matter because whole
institutions can be left by the wayside
wow uh there's a subtitle which is
called rehearsing the history now the
reason why I put that in
there is because whenever God does
something enormous or a new
phase is
introduced then he was uh prone to
rehearse the history mhm so that they
would understand where they are in the
Stream of time what is happening why it
is happening and how sh should they
should act in accordance to what is
happening and only a handful ever got
it I wonder if it's the same
today Martin don't be
factious people don't like history
that's the problem no and they don't
like the consequences or maybe I must
say they don't like studying history
correct and when there was a phase and
God's people weren't
ready they had to rehearse it over and
over until they got ready right now
we've been rehearsing now for a century
and a half and I don't think we've got
it together
8 so it's pretty pathetic so he
rehearsed their history and often it was
a very
scathing rehearsal yeah reminding them
of where they went wrong and why they
went wrong yeah because it's a serious
issue it's a very very serious issue
whole Nations whole systems just
disappear yeah if you don't take heed of
this situation
so let's put the verse there Psalm
77:13 thy way oh God is in the
sanctuary who is so great a God as our
God I like this translation in the King
James the others tend to become rather
nebulous and uh they they don't have
this this direct approach of this is
what God is saying
God does nothing separate from the
sanctuary that's the way he operates he
won't change
no the way that he's put it together oh
okay this is not working let's try
something else you know the law throw it
away the law is righteous and just and
good so it's useless let's throw it away
it justes doesn't make any sense right
true that's it you
can't if something's work looking why
change it yes and why get rid of your
government we've discussed that before
but it's very clear that the way of God
is in the
sanctuary and this is something that is
amazing because it it deals not only
with the individual it deals with
systems and it deals with Nations and it
deals with the entire world so it
escalates yeah and the more it escalates
the more you should take heed so if you
lose sight of the sanctuary Martin why
you get lost in the Quagmire definitely
it's there's no other way if your guide
is not there if the light is not there
that you should follow where you going
you're going to get lost all
right so this is not a discussion as I
said of what exactly happens in the
sanctuary it's just that God works in
the sanctuary mhm and if there was an
Earthly model then there is a literal
Heavenly yeah and in the book of Hebrews
it's very explicit we've dealt with it
many times there's no way you can
spiritualize those messages they are
direct
dandal so I've tried to put it together
in this way so let's have a look
whenever God's people went through a
period of change or a shift in God God's
way of dealing with them took place then
the history of their experience was
recited to them often this was the case
when through their stubbornness God was
forced to change their circumstances to
bring them to their
senses their history was rehearsed when
through Disobedience they had to return
to the Wilderness because of
unbelief when they went into captivity
or Exile or even when they returned from
their Exile their history was reversed
so that they understood why and what the
consequences were it was to remind them
of why the calamities happened in the
first place interestingly their history
was also rehearsed to them when a new
period in their experience was to
commence such as the entrance into
Canaan Moses in the book of Deuteronomy
rehearses the history of the Israelites
to 4 by them for their entrance into
Canaan it gives the whole history from
the
beginning so it is a rehearsal to remind
them of their experience their
shortcomings their victories but more
than this it was to remind them of the
power of God the miracles of god his
longsuffering his
Mercy it was their lesson book to
discern the character of God to know him
and to love him which which is the first
commandment would you agree with that
yeah that's beautiful love for God leads
to understanding and obedience to his
Commandments not because we must but
because we understand and let's add
there want to want to that's
it for me it's amazing while you were
reading this I I started realizing what
you meant is like every time you see in
the Bible you read a portion and then
you get to a portion where it's repeated
what happened how you apostasis how you
did this so now I understand why it's
repeated the whole time yes it's
constantly brought to their attention I
believe we're heading for the final
events which means that we're on the
threshold of entering a Heavenly Canan a
big shaft again uh should we rehearse a
little bit of History
here so Moses that given the children of
Israel a complete blueprint of the Plan
of Salvation couched in types and
symbols that was the sanctuary message
it explained the Plan of Salvation to a
te if you throw away the blueprint well
where will you end you could be riding
goats like the
Freemasons and think that you're on the
Plan of Salvation that's the
thing this blueprint was to be their
lesson book their study Through the Ages
it was was to lead them to an
understanding of the nature of sin its
consequences and the ultimate solution
for the sin problem sent it in the
Messiah the promised one they didn't
even realize that the
priest was just a type of Christ yeah
they weren't Christ themselves they
weren't to Lord it over others and and
take all the glory to them they were to
project this image to another that
should have been like John the Baptist
I'm not worthy to tie his
shoelaces he who comes after me is
greater than I am I'm not
worthy but they didn't right they
exalted themselves they didn't they just
didn't seem to get it so once again
that's a lesson book for us so the
sanctuary service was a stepbystep
expose of the Plan of
Salvation explaining in detail the
sacrifice the atonement the
mediation the cleansing and eradication
of
sin it even presented the conflict
between Christ and Satan in the form of
the Lord's goat and the scapegoat which
pointed to the originator of sin
everything was there yeah they could
have studied it but they made it a
ritual and the ritual became their
salvation unfortunately and the essence
was lost yeah that's a very dangerous
position to be in
so better learn from it we better learn
from it
exactly so question does this apply to
our time as
well oh that's an important question if
it was then it must be now as well right
we can't just read history and
say look at these people we worse than
they remember we did one yes worse than
that and it's important because now that
we realize God every time brings up
history so that you can learn from it
it's not there just there for a some
story so in reviewing our past history
this is a quote from uh spirit of
Prophecy having traveled over every step
of advance to our present standing I can
say praise God as I see what God has
wrought I'm filled with astonishment and
with confidence in Christ as leader we
have nothing to fear for the future
except as we forget the way the Lord has
led us and he's teaching in our past
history it's time for some serious
reflection MH but not only as a
denomination the whole world needs to
have some serious
reflection all right so let's continue
our discussion here so this is our words
again this Sanctuary service in annual
feasts and
ceremonies depicted the various stages
of the the
atonement and had the Jews internalized
each stage they would not as readily
have misinterpreted the scriptures
regarding the Messiah and his
mission had they Associated the lamb
slain with a messiah they would not have
ascribed the triumphant second coming to
the first coming almost 2,000 years
ago well they were thinking he's coming
to clean house no he was coming to clean
hearts and Minds it's 100% in that in
the thought um process it was selfish
and instead of yes it was
self-exaltation it was you know like
Calvinism selection I am I am the bees
knees and the rest are
garbage reminds me of the American
election where some people were also
assigned to the garbage bin yeah
all their history and wonderings would
have been seen in a new life type had to
first meet
antitype before there could be a
restoration of the kingdom of God so
Martin it's very important that we
understand what happened in the time of
Jews because it has an impact what
happens later on because we're following
God in the sanctuary remember yes so
besides the great prophetic themes
predict predicting the time of his
coming that's Daniel chapter
9 and the mission of the
Messiah as well as the numerous
typological
indicators there were many little
pointers to which Steve Walberg in his
book The Israel and the end of the world
gives a few examples quot some of him
Martin I was listening to a discourse by
Bishop marar
the Orthodox one who lives in Australia
who they stabbed the other day he's not
very kind towards Adventists he rather
despises them and their message and I
heard heard him uh just recently gave an
expose on Daniel chapter 9 and the 70
weeks
mhm I felt so sorry for him because he's
so confused but he's so determined to
make it seem that he's unconfused us
he's got all the times wrong everything
certain details are there but then of
course the the final week they love to
throw that into the future they start
with the wrong dates they there is
nothing of substance there they can't he
says it's the messiah's prophecy but he
he can't pinpoint it to any date or
anything like that so it's very sad how
they interpret that okay but the history
if you go back to the Reformation they
got it right they got it right and they
got the day princip day your principle
right so so the Jews remember forbade
the study of that prophecy because they
said well the time is gone so something
went wrong so let's start over again
they missed the point that's the whole
point but I mean like today you you're
not supposed to miss the point no
because there's the evidence is there
the but we've already missed the point
even today or let's say the bulk of the
churches have missed the point that's
the thing they're not supposed to even
like this bishop the evidence is there
it's been discovered again so Martin
they could have recognized the time the
Jews could have recognized the time they
had the exact date when the Messiah
would start you even mentioned the other
day the men from the East came to give
them a chance to go and restudy the
scriptures they had every opportunity to
know and there are a few subtle ones
that I quite like that uh Steve warberg
brought up so let's read some of
them in the Old Testament a man named
Joseph dreamed dreams and ended up in
Egypt in the New Testament another name
man named Joseph dreamed dreams and he
also ends up in Egypt it's sort of a
little subtle little things in there I
like it so Matthew 2:12 and being warned
of God in a dream that they should not
return to Herod they departed unto their
own country another way talking about
the wise men that you just
mentioned and when they were departed
behold the angel of the Lord appeared to
Joseph in a dream saying arise and take
the young child and his mother and flee
into Egypt and be thou there until I
bring thee word for Herod will seek the
Young child to destroy him
so they had all of these pointers their
nose was put onto the scriptures but
they chose to ignore him it wasn't only
that well he arose and he took the young
child and his mother by night and
departed into Egypt and there was there
until the death of Herod that it might
be fulfilled what was spoken of the Lord
by the prophet saying out of Egypt I
have called my
son so there's always this back and
forth study go back to your history go
back to your history and it shows you
also shows you that the Old Testament is
alive in the New Testament it comes
through you can't be without it you
can't be without the substance in the
new and the type in the old just a quick
one so this is also just very wonderful
about where it says in the Bible that
Jesus Through His prophets tells you
ahead of time something that will happen
that when it happens you may believe you
may believe yeah so here Matthew
actually quotes hosiah when he says when
Israel was a child then I loved him and
called my son out of Egypt now this is
fascinating because here he calls Israel
the son that he called out of Egypt in a
literal sense right but the New
Testament applies it to
Christ so in other words what we are
saying is the whole essence of the
Jewish system was to be Christ
centered everything was a type of
him and they made the type prominent and
the
antitype they cost the side yeah gives
you a beautiful tool of to to use in
Bible study yes so here God calls Israel
his son but Matthew applies it to Jesus
so this history of the Jews Finds Its
comp complete fulfillment in Jesus
Christ it's a beautiful
typology in Isaiah 41:8 God calls Israel
his
servant but here it is an Isaiah but
thou Israel are my servant Jacob whom I
have chosen the Seed of Abraham my
friend but Matthew applies the servant
as expanded in Isaiah to
Jesus so when we read this statement
behold my servant whom I uphold my elect
in whom my soul delighteth I have put my
spirit upon him he shall bring forth
judgment to the Gentiles he shall not
cry nor lift up nor cause his voice to
be heard in the
street a bruised Reed shall he not break
and the smoking flax shall he not quench
he shall bring forth judgment and Truth
he shall not fail nor be discouraged
till he have set judgment in the earth
and the shall wait for his law so this
is applied to Jesus Christ right now
Martin when it says he shall not cry nor
lift up nor cause his voice to be heard
in the street you could counter argue
and say but Jesus taught in the streets
and in the public places and everybody
heard his
voice so is the Bible contradicting
itself here no because you must look at
what the Pharisees did they cried in the
streets and lifted up their voice to
exalt themselves yeah he didn't do it to
exalt himself he was pointing to the
Plan of Salvation that's why they say
nor cause his voice to be heard it's not
self Center there was no
self-centeredness and this of course is
totally contrary to the Fallen nature of
man we're very self- centered
particularly you of course right
definitely don't don't worry we all have
the same problem I know I know everybody
is so all right in Psalms 80 ver8 Israel
is called the vine but Jesus says he's
the True Vine so all of these are type
types
enacted
stories Israel is called The Seed of
Abraham in Isaiah 41:8 and Paul in
Galatians 316 States now to Abraham and
his seed were the promises made
referring to to
Israel he says not unto seeds as of many
but as of one and to thy seed which is
Christ so in other words again you have
the Fulfillment is in Jesus the whole
time now it must be hard when you think
the Fulfillment is in you and you have
to give up that prized position and give
it to someone else and say I'm not
worthy to untie shoelaces or to tie
shoelaces so therefore anyone that is in
Christ is Abraham's seed right this is
according to Galatians 3:29 according to
the promise so everything was centered
on Christ and they had everything
centered upon
themselves therefore they lost sight of
Christ no he became their enemy yeah he
had to be eradicated otherwise self
can't reain yeah so this vital point was
missed by the
Jews the kingdom that Adam lost was to
be restored to the descendants of Adam
Adam was the father of all right
y so act
17:26 tells us and he has made of one
blood all nations of men for to dwell on
all the face of the Earth and has
determined the times before appointed
and the bounds of their habitation is he
in control of all of humanity and the
Nations as well yes all right so is all
of these under control they're all
written down and if we are really Christ
centered we should be able to understand
where we are in the Stream of
time so then you have a second Adam who
died for the whole of humanity right
yeah and whosoever believeth he is the
savior of all is there any exclusivity
in that no all it's encompassing can one
nation
deem itself more privileged than another
Nations no that was the downfall in the
first place okay could could one nation
claim to have a nobler beginning than
another Nation if they were all from
that seed mod do we have racial
Prejudice in the world oh full on
everywhere
everywhere there must be some utopic
place where it's not there like how
about the Lord's Church it shouldn't be
there right yeah no definitely not I'm
sorry we a bit
sarcastic Martin it's not nice it's the
lowest form of wit yeah so let me be
then blunt there is racism in church
okay so uh should it be eradicated from
the soul
yes all right some nations are less
privileged than others yeah that we can
say okay but are they less important in
the of God no all right so if we could
only get that into our heads wouldn't we
have a much more harmonious existence
for sure for God so loved the world that
only those Nations who he chose as his
special treasure should be saved and the
other should perish that's what it says
there in John 3:16 right I think I need
glasses because what I've read is not
the same oh so let me put on the right
glasses here for God so loved the world
that he gave his only begot Otten
son that this very B big word over here
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish but have everlasting life there
goes exclusivity 100%
whosoever means you have a choice that
must be
so so can we say that at the first
coming of Christ type had met
antitype Christ did not come to minister
in the
Holy nor in the Most Holy he only
ministered to the people in the
courtyard is that correct yes in fact
what would have happened had he gone
into the holy or the most holy he would
have been they would have stoned him yes
he would have been killed he would have
been killed yes because that was a
litical uh ruling only the
levite was allowed to serve in the holy
and the most holy the courtyard was for
even the Gentiles there was even a place
for
them and Christ's entire Ministry while
on Earth was in the
courtyard now also part of the courtyard
was the sacrificial system where the
where the lamb was sacrificed yeah so he
fulfilled the courtyard
Ministry while he was on on Earth yeah
he never officiated in the holy or the
most holy now if his way is in the
sanctuary then at some stage he must go
to the holy right you must complete the
whole thing all right so the levitical
priesthood had to come to an
end it had to come totally to an end
because Christ our high priest was not a
levite yeah but a
Judean and thus not a Ministry of the
inner Temple he was of a higher
priesthood yeah he was of the order of
meis
sedc he was the sacrificial lamb whose
blood was shed for the sins of the world
that could happen because I was out a
courtyard but he couldn't be an Earthly
priest because he was not a
levite so neither by the blood of goats
and cves but by his own blood he entered
once into the holy Place have having
obtained Eternal Redemption for us
wherefore Jesus also that he may
sanctify the people with his own blood
suffered without the
gate he had a
courtyard
Ministry and he fulfilled that portion
of the Plan of Salvation he paid for the
sins of the whole of
humanity and then he went into the holy
Place according to Hebrews
9:12 but the Leal priesthood had to come
to an end before he could do that yeah
cuz he was not a levite
question if you were a fancy levite with
fancy robes with much pump and glamour
surrounding you would that please you if
you were suddenly null and void no of
course you will
be envious so it's better that one man
gets eradicated than that we all lose
our position and our ministry right
yeah okay that's very important mm so
Psalms 110:4 the Lord has sworn and he
will not repent thou art a priest
Forever After the order of meis sadc
this is the Messianic promise Hebrews
5:6 tells us as he says also in another
place thou art a priest Forever After
the order of meis sedc Hebrews 711
if therefore Perfection were by the
litical priesthood for under it the
people received the
law what further need was there that
another priest should arise after the
order of meis sedc and not be called
after the order of
Aaron it's a good question that Paul is
asking exactly if it weren't like that
there will be no use so can we say that
if God's way is in the sanctuary
then the higher priesthood and the
ministration of Jesus in the Holy took
place after the crucifixion that's very
biblical right
definitely resurrection and Ascension of
Jesus because then only was his own
blood available for the consecration of
the temple and the officiation in the
Holy place yes inen he couldn't start
the ministry before the blood was there
yeah and this holy place is in heaven in
the Heavenly it's the Heavenly because
in never officiated in the Holy on on
the earth even while the temple was
still standing he never went in there
after his Ascension and said now I am
the priest of the order of meis EDC get
out Levites no no he never did that he
entered into the higher Temple that was
not made by hands so M what happened
here there was a seismic shift in the
Plan of Salvation that took place type
had made anti type would you agree with
that yeah definitely so I'm going to
talk about seismic shifts this is a mega
change from an Earthly model to a
literal Heavenly
salvation it suddenly made the Earthly
model
obsolete the only purpose that it still
served was as a lesson book as to what's
happening in the in the Heavenly yeah it
was a blueprint yeah you don't throw it
in the waste paper basket but you no
longer enact it because it has been
fulfilled yeah
okay is it almost like if you got a
blueprint for an airplane after you've
built the airplane you can refer back to
the blueprint but you're not going to
build the airplane again no you're not
going to build the airplane again you're
right all right those that had followed
Jesus by faith into the holy place
because because you couldn't follow him
literally you had to Now by
faith follow him now when the priest
went into the holy you could wait
outside and you know what he was doing
inside there because it was precisely
prescribed as to what he should do in
there but now that the Earthly was no
longer valid and the Heavenly had been
inaugurated by by faith you follow what
Jesus does in there because you have the
blueprint yeah yeah exactly all right
but you don't have to with your nose
walk around a maze on Earth to enact it
you do it by faith exactly so those that
followed Jesus by faith into the holy
Place had found the new and better way
his ministration replaced the feasts and
ceremonies on which so many had placed
their hopes forgetting that they merely
foreshadowed a greater reality are you
concurrence 100 100% that's for sure so
those that refused to accept this new
and better way continued with their
rights and rituals not realizing that
their house had been left to them
desolate yeah so they were staying
behind while Jesus moved forward can we
say they were playing Church yes they
were playing church and carried on as
before
not realizing that Jesus was no longer
involved there they had to shift their
emphasis to the
Heavenly M they could have become
pastors
yeah but they could no longer be priests
yeah because a priest is someone who
brings a sacrifice that's it a pastor
ministers yeah it's like a Shepherd mhm
so their system need not have
disappeared but their priesthood would
have
disappeared and the rituals that they
performed would be gone yeah so Martin
think about that what if a Christian
organization de said decides we want to
be priests and still carry on
sacrificing wouldn't that be a negation
of the Plan of Salvation definitely it
will be blasphemy it will be saying
Jesus is not we don't agree oh you
actually negate him completely then all
right so there goes
Catholicism cuz they have a priesthood
and a sacrifice there goes Orthodoxy
because they have a priesthood and a
sacrifice and there
goes anglicanism because they have a
priesthood and a
sacrifice
gone
gone they're doing exactly the same that
the Jews did yeah Martin is that a large
port portion of what is called the
Christian church today mega mega right
at the whole Orthodox the whole Anglican
the whole Catholic
system then there's a spattering
left oh what happens to the spattering
that's left Martin it's a sad story but
let's continue so they were officiating
in an Earthly ritual that no longer had
any
validity John 11:15 says now consider
that it is expedient for us that one man
should die for the people and that the
whole nation perish not they must have
had some vague idea of what was
happening and realized that if people
followed
Jesus their system was gone yeah so
let's get rid of the man and keep our
system now it was cayapas right now
Caiaphas was he which gave counsel to
the Jews that it was expedient that one
man should die for the people this is
the high priest we're going to keep our
offers we're going to keep our
sacrifices we're not going to accept
this one it's over the system is
useless it has no meaning it is desolate
devoid of anything I think it's very
important that we learn from this okay
did they did they accept it no no they
did didn't accept it all right we're
going somewhere with this I can see
we're going somewhere defitely we're
going so what happened then the breaking
down of the wall of partition between
the Jew and the Gentile that wasn't
acceptable to many of them because it
got rid of their exclusivity yeah so
anybody who thinks that they're the bees
needes today is suffering from the same
delusion the end of the sacrificial
system with its types and Shadow
yeah the end of the leidal
priesthood and the opening of a new and
better way is that basically what
happened definitely and well in a sense
you can understand why this shook them
because the whole nation was built
around these the whole thing was built
around it it's devastating but had they
accepted it they would have rejoiced
they would have rejoiced they wouldn't
have had to have the temple system
anymore and they could have become
pastors and they would and they could
have held their position of course they
and be like the disciples was yes maybe
they could have gotten rid of their
fancy robes to make them more important
than others what about the the Christian
churches same don't they love their
robes robes if you want to put it in a
they like did Jesus walk around in a
fancy robe no he had a beautiful one but
it wasn't fancy it was just a white
seamless righteous
okay well if you think of it we still
have Herod buildings
today yes and all of they want to go big
and better than the next well let's
continue our story so Romans 7:6 says
but now we are delivered from the law
talking about the ceremonial law let's
not get confused here that being dead
wherein we were held that we should
serve in a newness of spirit and not in
the oldness of the letter so let's get
rid of the ritual because by faith we're
following Christ into the sanctuary now
because his way is in the sanctuary he
doesn't change his
plot Hebrews 8 but now has he obtained a
more excellent Ministry by how much also
he is the media of a mediator of a
better Covenant which was established
upon on better
promises upon a reality not Upon A type
no so that's you have to understand this
correct not that the first one was
useless no it was just a symbol yeah a
lamb didn't die for me no the Jesus died
for what the lamb stood for died for yes
it was therefore necessary that the
patterns of things in the heavens should
be purified by these but the Heavenly
things themselves by better sacrifices
than these if the Earthly had to be
cleansed then the Heavenly so much more
by better sacrifices namely the
sacrifice of Christ
himself and then this very sad
verse he came unto his own and his own
received him not John 111 now Mar this
is the history of the Jews we look back
upon them and we say how silly yeah and
we say uh-huh and then we repeat it and
we do a better job of it yeah right
worse than they okay let's just check
this out so would you agree this must be
one of the saddest verses in the Bible
for sure it has a parallel verse the one
that says that I know you
not he was acknowledged by the wise men
of the
East Angels announced him to the
Shepherds prophets of the House of
Israel officiated in the temple
confirmed him and he was heralded by
John the Baptist who pointed out the
Lamb of God he was acknowledged by the
Holy Spirit when it came down upon him
like a dove
right by his father's voice from Heaven
by his miracles and his Transfiguration
and his resurrection and nobody accepted
him they had every opportunity would you
agree for sure did God want to make dou
sure yeah let's read it and beheld there
was a man in Jerusalem whose name was
Simeon and the same man was just and
devout waiting for the consolation of
Israel and the Holy Ghost was upon him
and it was revealed unto him by the holy
ghost that he should not see death
before he had seen the Lord Jesus Christ
and he came by the spirit into the
temple and when the parents brought in
the Child Jesus to do for him after the
custom of the law
then took him up in his arms and blessed
God and said Lord now letest thou thy
servant depart in peace according to Thy
word for mine eyes have seen thy
salvation which thou has prepared before
the face of all people a light to
lighten the Gentiles and the glory of
thy People
Israel and Joseph and his mother
marveled at those things which were
spoken of him here was a
prophet waiting and he was telling the
whole of Israel what was
happening and God wanted to make sure
that there wasn't only one
witness so what else did he
do and Simeon blessed them and said unto
Mary's mother behold this child is set
for the Fallen Rising again of many in
Israel and for a sign which shall be
spoken
against interesting right
yeah a sword shall pierce through thy
own soul also that the thoughts of many
hearts may be revealed it's all about
the
heart and then there was one Anna
prophetes the daughter of fuel of the
tribe of Essa and she was of great age
and had lived with a husband seven years
from her
virginity and she was a widow of about
about 4 score and4
years which departed not from the temple
but served god with fasting and prayer
night and day and she coming in that
instant gave thanks likewise unto the
Lord and spake of him to all them that
looked for redemption in
Jerusalem two
prophets besides the wise men besides
all the signs and you had John the
Baptist preparing the way those time
okay were they without excuse they were
without excuse right if they had studied
it they were without excuse yes yes if
they had
studied they would not have missed the
Messiah possible well when the men from
the East came they had to study and then
there was willful ignorance yes then it
was willful ignorance no it was actual
willful murder because Herod decided to
kill all the little boys because he he
alone wanted to be king he had exactly
the same attitude as
kaius so at the end of the Jewish era at
the end of the 70 we prophecy that
heralded the close of probation for the
Jewish
Nation at the stoning of
Steven the history of the Jews was again
presented to them in Steven's speech
this is all recorded in Acts chapter 7
which took place under the inspiration
of the Holy Spirit and is recorded in
Acts chapter 7 they were without
excuse when he recorded that history and
said now finally you've come to the
Messiah and you are guilty of killing
him they stoned him right yeah so they
didn't take the
rebuke we read in the Desire of Ages the
Savior had not come to set aside what
Patriarchs and Prophets had spoken for
he himself had spoken through these
representative men all the truths of God
word came from him but these Priceless
gems had been placed in false
settings their precious light had been
made to minister to
error God desired them to be removed
from their setting of error and replaced
in the framework of Truth this work only
a divine hand could
accomplish by its connection with error
the truth had been serving the cause of
the enemy of God and man Christ had come
to place it where it would glorify God
and work the salvation of
humanity Martin they were without excuse
they had all of these
rituals and they' made them although
they were given by God exactly their
salvation they made them their
the wrong thing the Salvation to that
what to whom it was pointing they
totally well they killed him and then
Jesus said your house is left for you
desolate because they didn't follow him
by faith into the next part of the
ministry the seismic shift from an
Earthly model to a literal reality they
had to follow him in the Sanctuary
because his way is in the sanctuary into
the holy they could have become
ministers but they chose to remain
priests
yeah so the house was desolate so let's
read in one spiritual
gifts about their demise the blood of
Christ and of the disciples whom they
had put to death was upon them and in
terrible judgments were they visited the
curse of God God followed them and they
were a byword and a derision to the
Heathen and to Christians they were
shunned degraded detested as though the
brand of Cain was upon them yet I
saw that God marvelously preserved this
people now this is very interesting
modern he preserved them what to give
them the same status again no read
carefully he marvelous preserved this
people and had scattered them over the
world that they might be looked upon as
especially visited by the curse from God
sure most Nations love them today right
yes certain groups love them but most
hate them most despised despised them so
the hatred hasn't
gone I saw that God has
forsaken the Jews as a nation not as
individuals it's very important
the same applies to people in false
systems God cares for the
individuals but he
reprimands the systems of course it's
like when we read about being the Seed
of Abraham there is a criteria to
qualify not stuck in a system that
negates it
corre so he had forsaken the Jews as a
nation yet there was a portion of them
who would be enable to tear away the
veil from their hearts some will yet see
the prophet that prophecy has been
fulfilled concerning them and they will
receive Jesus as the savior of the world
and see the great sin of their nation in
rejecting Jesus and crucifying him
individuals amongst the Jews will be
converted but as a nation
Martin they are forever forsaken of God
you cannot make the statement your house
is
desolate a statement which says your
house is not
desolate you cannot say you
are you are now desolate but you will be
restored it doesn't say that that is the
important thing there's no restoration
again no the house is desolate it's
finished it's over as a nation and
should they bring in their systems again
it would be a blasphemy towards God so
as individuals they can be saved so M
Christ had moved from an Earthly outer
Court
ministry as a
Judean into the order of meis cedc into
the final priesthood the high priest in
the Holy Place yeah in heaven they
didn't Follow by faith the house was
desolate so we can say he came to his
own and his own did not receive him he
came to those that He redeemed from the
blight of sin but their
self-righteousness was of greater value
to them than his Redemption would you
agree
y he came to his own to those to whom he
had given great
light Jesus and the disciples did not
start a new church we've said this a
hundred times
where the Messiah is there is the
church so all that is required of his
followers is to hear his voice and to
follow yeah would you agree with that
yes so he says my sheep hear my
voice the sheep that refused to hear his
voice did not
follow but they condemned yes they were
so they were busy with an Earthly
priesthood that was obsolete playing
their rituals with their fancy little
robes when Christ was ministering in the
Holy place they should have been with
him by faith in the Holy Place yeah
pointing towards
that so there was no new church which is
called Christianity no that's a that's a
problem because people believe it is yes
it was just actually
Christianity was what you could have
called the Jews because the everything
in the sanctuary was pointing to Christ
correct so Christianity merely
acknowledged the Messiah that the
majority had
rejected they did not recognize the
voice of the B bridegroom and shook
themselves
out Jesus never left the regular line
they left him would you agree with that
yes many even of the F Pharisees
eventually believed on him and followed
him but they stopped being priests and
Pharisees then yes so can we say that
the Sheep that
followed had need of redemption okay so
we're all sheep right the fact that we
followed by faith into the holy doesn't
make us better than anyone we just
listen to his voice but we still needed
of redemption for sure for sure so we're
no better than anyone else we haven't
suddenly become
superhuman so physically and spiritually
we need Redemption yeah because this
body is going to rot one day yeah yeah
and if it's not resurrected I'm done for
yeah and the only way I can be
resurrected is if I am in Christ that's
it and I have a fallen nature and I
cannot get rid of it unless Christ
renews me and justifies me m and
sanctifies so he came to seek the
Brokenhearted he came to change the
hard-hearted to the
soft-hearted some the disciples or we
are not better than anyone else because
of this
because Jesus said ye know not the
spirit ye are
of so there had to be a change of heart
all of us had to have a change of heart
everybody his Redemption is complete he
is faithful and just to forgiv and to
redeem from all
unrighteousness he never went faster
than his children could
follow that's a very important statement
yes I think so yeah
more than this he placed himself in
their path and took time to help them
MH so for example the woman with the
issue and everybody thought he was
delaying and some were getting
hyperactive and nervous we tend to do it
still he was on his way to heal someone
but took time to seek someone in need he
was never late even if he was supposedly
late would you agree with that 100% yes
so he didn't fly ahead at supersonic
speed when he said follow me they had an
opportunity to go through the process
right now Martin all of that was to
actually prepare the mind for the next
seismic
shift would you
agree that if he served in the outer
Court in the time of the
Jews and then moved to the holy place
there was a seismic Chi that changed the
whole scenario yeah no for sure so M
mustn't he then at some stage go into
the most holy yes isn't that his way in
the
sanctuary all right now this gets
serious now yeah because we're on the
verge of reenacting what the Jews did
just improving on it on a universal
scale whereas theirs was a local scale
all right so what's the next seismic
shift well if you go to Daniel 8:14 and
he said unto me unto
2,300 days then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed
so when was this to take place well if
you work this prophecy out it's part of
the 70 week prophecy or the 70 week
prophecy is part of this prophecy let's
put it that way this first and the first
portion dealt with the Jews and we just
dealt with it there will be a second
portion when the sanctuary will be
cleansed and that took place on the day
of atonement that's it well it was like
Israel was the the local and now we've
got the universal so now it's on a
worldwide scale It's the End of Time
right well the time of the end let's put
it that way so Martin at the end of the
2,300 day prophecy the sanctuary was to
be cleansed now when this message was
first preached they thought well what's
the sanctuary all about because they'd
lost sight of the sanctuary
yeah and so they postulated that this
Sanctuary must be the Earth and Christ
would come again he didn't come this
prophecy ends in 1844 it's plain
mathematics it's not some some magic
formula and in 1844 many interesting
thing happens and we can talk about that
in a moment but the fact of the matter
is the cleansing of the Earthly
Sanctuary Was the removal of the record
of sin which took place on the day of
atonement when Christ would go from the
holy to the most holy must you then also
follow him into the most holy yes
otherwise you're going to be now what
was in the most holy the Ark of the
Covenant ah and the Ten Commandments
were inside there right so the
interpretation of the vision and it came
to pass when I even I Daniel had seen
the vision and sought for the meaning
then behold there stood before me as the
appearance of a man and I heard a man's
voice between the banks of OI which
called and said Gabriel make this man to
understand the
vision so Gabriel is the Angel right he
came near Where I Stood and when he came
I was afraid and fell upon my face but
he said unto me understand oh son of me
man for at the time of the end shall be
the
vision now once you do a big study on
that you will see that that started not
at the end of the
1844 end of the 2,300 but at the end of
the
1,260 day prophecy referring to papal
Supremacy and that was 1798 correct so
when the pap Supremacy as a political
entity should end in
1798 then the these words will begin to
be understood yes then certain things
would start to happen that you can
visually see that this is happening yes
but it won't happen before that because
verse 9 of chapter 12 says the words are
closed up and sealed till the time of
the end so till 7 then he tells you
that's at the end of the 1,260 days many
shall be purified and made white and
tried but the wicked shall do wickedly
and none of the wicked shall understand
and the wise shall understand so M to be
wise you need to ask God for wisdom and
study his word to see what it says not
what you think it says yeah but go thy
way till the end be for Thou shalt rest
and stand in thy lot in the end of days
so what does it mean to stand in thy lot
it's interesting question isn't it
definitely it's important to know when
would the officiation and the most holy
begin it's also important for sure at
the end of the 2,300 right because
that's when the sanctuary would be
cleansed that's the day of
atonement the Hebrew word for lot is
G and this word is used 77 times in the
Old Testament it is the same word that
is used in the typical cleansing of the
sanctuary where Lots were cost to
determine which the Two Goats was to be
slain so it's definitely D have
atonement language yeah on this day the
Israelites stood outside the temple
afflicting their souls and confessing
their sins that they might receive the
blessing of the high priest when he came
out of the sanctuary now when you are
confessing your sins aren't you
confessing the transgression of the law
yes wasn't the high priest offici before
the law mhm so in the day of atonement
was the law The Ten Commandments
prominent is or not for sure okay on
that day Israel stood in their lot mhm
so so on the final anti-typical day of
cleansing the cases of the righteous
dead would come into review before God
and Daniel too would thus stand in his
lot so so in other words his record of
judgment would come up that's it you're
you're waiting for the verdict that
doesn't mean he's standing there waiting
no his record will be
discussed and he will be declared fit
for heaven or unfit for
heaven correct M so this is referring to
the day of atonement Daniel you'll stand
in your lot your name will also come up
in that judgment
and sooner or later the Judgment of the
living will begin then your and my name
will come up in the Judgment we're all
going to have to stand in the lot is
standing in your lot almost like
standing there in the courtroom waiting
for judgment to be given correct you're
waiting for that judgment when that when
that judge comes out and he knocks with
his
gavel and the sentence is passed then it
is too late yeah then it is too late so
Martin this is sanctuary language now
this is important what happens this is a
quote from Jay and lofer the great
second Advent movement its rise and
progress I would encourage people to
read these books you can get them for
free from the
internet so writes when the prophetic
Clock Struck and the time of the end was
ushered in after the 1,2 260 prophetic
days which ended in 1798 remember when
the papacy lost its political power
yeah many of the wise studied the
scriptures to determine the end of the
2300 day prophecy and many of the wise
began to understand this is important
this is a universal thing that's
happening true yeah so let's rehearse
the history let's study these things all
of the world and independently from each
other people came to the conclusion that
the prophetic period would come to a
close around 1843 to
1844 different places different
places heading the list was William
Miller AJ kpp David McGregor Edward
Irving in England Aral Mason from
Scotland we Davis Jose wolf who labored
in Asia Alexander Campbell captain aers
of Liverpool England lard Hinrich calba
from Germany launa from Spain hensa Peta
and Dr capad DOI from Holland the ra of
Pia Priests of tarty Bible students of
Yemen Russians on the Caspian Sea and
moccas on the shores of the Baltic and
many many others discerned the times did
you know that Mar no I did not know that
isn't this important it's amazing this
is like the men from the East so here a
light goes up what are they doing
they're rehearsing history they're
studying prophecy did the men from the
East study prophecy yes yes they
discerned the time of Daniel yeah and
then they came and they said well this
star must be this
prophecy so these men from the East they
weren't Jews no so they were probably
zor
Asians and they had access to what
Daniel had said and they were studying
these
things here all of these people all over
the world from Asia to the Christian
World from the Dutch to the British to
the Germans to the
spats Catholic countries Protestant
countries Pagan countries they were
studying these things and they came to
realize that the end of the
2,300 was to be around about 1843 and
1844 so God was giving them a history
lesson again before a seismic shift
before a seismic shift he was going to
change the
ministration from the holy to the most
holy now remember the Jews had missed it
when he went into the holy and their
system was left to them desol yeah so
what did milliam Miller have to say the
impact of Bible chronology another kind
of evidence that vitally affected my
mind he says was the chronology of the
scriptures I found that predicted events
which had been fulfilled in the past
often occurred within a given time the
120 years to the flood Genesis 63 the
the seven days that were to preed it
with 40 days of predicted rain Genesis
7:4 the 400 years of the sge of Abraham
seed Genesis 1513 are they rehearsing
history
beautifully the three days of the
Butlers and Baker's dream Genesis 40 the
seven years of
pharaohs the 40 years in the wilderness
numbers 1434 the 3 and A2 years of
famine 1 King
171 the 70 years of captivity Jeremiah
2511 Nebuchadnezzar seven times Daniel
413 to 16 the seven weeks three score
and two
weeks and the one week making 70 weeks
determined upon the Jews Daniel 9:24-27
the events Limited by these times were
all once only a matter of Prophecy and
were fulfilled in accordance with the
predictions so this is what they studied
and they came up with these
amazing realizations that the
2,300 were coming to an end when
therefore he found in his study of the
Bible various chronological periods that
according to his understanding of them
extended to the second coming of Christ
he could not but regard them as the
times before appointed which God had
revealed unto his servants the secret
things says Moses belong unto the Lord
Our God but those things which are
revealed belong unto us and to our
children
forever and the Lord declares by the
prophet Amos that he will do nothing but
he Reveals His secret unto his servants
his the prophets so that's another story
in itself yeah
Deuteronomy
29:29 Amos 37 the students of God's word
may then confidently expect to find the
most stupendous event to take place in
human history clearly pointed out in the
scripture of Truth yeah so God set these
specific
times he wrote as I was fully convinced
says Miller that all scripture given by
inspiration of God is profitable
that it may not at any time that it
didn't come by the will of man but was
written as holy men were moved by the
Holy Ghost and was written for our
learning that we through patience and
comfort of the scriptures might have
hope quoting Romans I could but regard
the chronological portions of the Bible
as being as much a portion of the word
of God As Much entitled to our serious
con consideration as any other portion
of scripture I therefore felt that in an
Endeavor to comprehend what God had in
his Mercy seen fit to reveal to us I had
no right to pass over the prophetic
periods mtin would God put the prophetic
periods in there for our Amusement for
sure not hey did he put the 70 weeks and
the time to the Messiah in there for the
amusement or the ignoring of of the Jews
did he put Revelation in there just to
close it that you don't don't read it
exactly so throw it aside because it's
useless you can't understand it but
there's a blessing upon understanding it
and taking it to heart it doesn't make
any
sense all right let's look at some of
the important milestones in the Plan of
Salvation because we want to know where
things can go wrong
right there was an announcement to Adam
of the Savior to come right yeah I will
put enmity yes okay the promise restored
to Noah and his sons After the
flood then there was the call of
Abraham then the Jewish Nation as the
represented of God and the Plan of
Salvation he called the Jewish Nation
the first coming of Christ the turning
point of History this is where the price
is
paid the ministration in the Holy place
of the Heavenly Temple begins correct y
then there's a falling away the
1,260 day prophecy
unfolds the Christian church starts
doing what the Jews did no they
reinstated the priesthood and lost sight
of Christ in the sanctuary that's it
rather sad right
yeah the Reformation After the Dark Ages
to put the record straight so they
stopped the priesthood they got rid of
the sacrifices they became ministers
like the Jews should have become yeah
they set the record straight then the
Oxford movement came and they said no
excuse me let's go back to the
priesthood and make this null and void
and put the emphasis back on Earth it's
pathetic it's pathetic and infiltrated
everything so the Reformation After the
Dark Ages truth is restored under much
tribulation and persecution from all
sides both Catholic and Protestants
that's it because the Lutheran wouldn't
go further than Luther the calvinist
wouldn't go further than Calvin
everybody stopped there the
Presbyterians didn't go further than KNX
etc etc didn't you you remember you
actually showed that even they they
couldn't even pray anything else than
the prayers that the fathers prayed yes
all right and then after this
persecution the Earth helps the woman
mhm so she flees to a new place and then
the end of the 2,300 day prophecy and
Christ's officiating in the Most Holy
begins so the time of judgment has come
cu the law is the standard of judgment I
it 18 so basically Martin once you
realize that that Christ has moved into
the holy place you should be looking
seriously at the law yes would you
discover that there's a problem with the
fourth Commandment mhm because that's on
the seventh day and everybody's keeping
the first day yeah because the law is
now being elevated again you see this is
going to happen so now you want to see
what's going wrong and obviously you can
see that's blatantly but if you stay on
Earth you'll stay with tradition y
whereas if you follow into the most holy
place you will realize uh uh I've got to
keep the law according to the letter
yeah can I take out the second
commandment and keep statues and bow
down to Idols no no because the second
commandment is in that
decalogue right can I split the ninth
the 10th one into two you cannot can I
change the wording no cannot touch it
what can I throw it away no because
you're going to be judged by it you
can't even chisel on it
okay all right so M at the end of the
2,300 if you follow Christ into the most
holy the law must become very prominent
because you're going to be judged by it
you have to ask yourself like the
Israelites am I in harmony with God and
if I'm not in harmony with the law
because of my traditions must a change
for sure and if I don't want to sorry
then you're going to not go are we going
to follow the way of the Jews and become
desolate M all right let's carry
on so
then truth lost is restored in settings
of
gold right the Jews the Jews had lost
sight of the truth and put it into false
settings didn't the Christian world do
the same thing spearheaded by
Catholicism reintroducing a priesthood
mhm spearheaded by the Orthodox and the
anglicans reintroducing a priesthood MH
the other churches started negating the
law and keeping a false law yeah whereas
the true standard is written with the
Finger of God and is in the most holy
yeah so when Christ goes into the most
holy I must follow him by faith that's
it and I must ask what are you doing
Lord I am judging the time of the
Judgment has come Daniel is standing in
the lot I'm going to see did he keep the
law m is he in harmony with my
principles and your name's coming up my
friend yeah so I must say Lord what is
the what is the standard whereby you
judging me where can I read about this
law and what the consequences are right
here in the Ark of the Covenant written
with the Finger of God if you want to
understand what they say go and read
Exodus chap 20 and get the gist of it
right and see what your situation is but
Lord I have a tradition which which is
contrary to your law I prefer to keep
the tradition well then you go the way
of the Jews my friend that's it all
right let's carry the for in vain you
worship me so the truth lost had to be
restored in settings of goal the image
of the Beast is formed after the this
mhm and the mark of the beast is
implemented and then you have a time of
trouble such as never was yeah the
consequence Martin of
rejecting the change the seismic
shift and then you have the second
coming so if we have a rest history
lesson yes we all 11 is already passed
yes we almost at number 12 we're almost
there all right so why did the end of
the
2,300 day prophecy Herald a seismic
shift in the Plan of
Salvation well the anti-typical day of
judgment the day of atonement had been
announced by the proclamation of the
first Angel's
message yeah it said the time of his
judgment has come y worship Him who made
made 1844 Evolution goes into the world
1844 go and worship who made goes into
the world
1844 you can't be in
eism with a system that has
rejected Christ by reintroducing a
priesthood and changing God's
law no we can we will worship our
tradition isn't that what the Jews did
even in the first Angel's message there
was already acknowledgement in that
Creator God that you should be reminded
of the Sabbath correct you can't be
bound to error no so you have to
separate from error right and if Christ
moved into the most holy and the law has
become prominent and there is a
contradiction with that law in the
system if you stick to the contradiction
you've shaken yourself out yeah
okay so Martin the anti-typical day of
atonement had had been announced by the
proclamation of the first
Angel Christ had moved from the holy to
the most holy those that followed him by
faith into the most
holy discovered the immutability of the
law and became Heralds of the second and
third Angel's messages yes those who
didn't accept no the principles of
judgment the time of his judgment has
come Martin they fell Unfortunately they
fell
and they never took part of the second
Angel because the second Angel says
sorry Babylon has fallen yeah and the
third Angel says if you carry on in your
way and you do what tradition says and
not what my law says you're going to be
in
trouble so what happened to the churches
who refused to
follow some of them were saying the law
is
changed some of them were saying the law
is no more
mhm and some of them were saying we are
a law unto ourselves
yeah as in the case of the Jewish Nation
before them would you agree that the
house became desolate
yes they had fallen they had fallen
because they drank of the wine of
fornication yeah it's false Doctrine do
they have an excuse no because the law
is very explicit they refused to accept
it and the history like with all the
Jews was brought up again to study all
right so let me now be very
blunt any denomination Protestant or
otherwise that rejects the letter of the
law of
God did not follow by faith into the
holy Place definitely therefore like the
Jewish nation is forever forsaken of God
those systems are forever forsaken of
God individuals like in the case of the
Jews can be
if they come back into harmony with the
principles of God and notice what he's
doing in the most holy Place namely
judging according to the law yes huh so
by implication that means you to keep to
the law all right Mar now this is very
serious are you telling me now that you
agree that let's say the anglicans as a
denomination having reintroduced the
priesthood and accepted a spous law as
Changed by Roman Catholicism and not as
the law before which Christ is
officiating in the most holy that their
house is desolate yeah yes it's become a
Freemason Nest unfortunately then what
about methodists yeah what about
congregationalists for sure what about
what about what about any denom
comination we've seen that doesn't
acknowledge the letter of the law yeah
has become desolate it has and you can
see by their fruits
eventually we must talk about
that so the way of God is in the
sanctury in this time of probation when
the people of God are to stand in their
lot mhm we have a message to Bear the
proclamation of the Three Angels
messages the IAL truths buried under the
sands of time are to be restored and the
spirit of true protestantism is to be
revived now protestantism didn't go far
enough they had an opportunity at the
Council of Trent when that Archbishop of
Rego got up and says but you say you're
Bible only but you're keeping our
tradition by keeping
Sunday if you were truly doing what the
Bible said you would not be doing that
right okay
okay as God does nothing without
revealing his secrets to the prophets
this seismic shift was also to be
accompanied by revelations from his
servants the
prophets so M the spirit of Prophecy was
to be part of the remnant church as a
light shining on the greater light of
the prophecies and events outlined in
the scriptures so the ministration in
the most holy
is soon going to come to an end yeah
Martin when that Ministry comes to an
end then sentence is pronounced then
it's too late it's finished it's
finished
Martin the system is desolate yeah they
have rejected the move from the holy to
the most holy they haven't reflected on
the standard of judgment they are not
aware that Jesus is Calling up their
name and asking have you broken my law
which is the definition of
sin so we read in one selected messages
it is the duty of the people of God to
have their lamps trimmed and burning to
be as the men that wait for the
bridegroom when he shall return from the
wedding you have not a moment to lose in
neglect of the great salvation that has
been provided for you the of probation
of souls is coming to an
end from day to day the destiny of men
is being sealed and even from this
congregation we know not how soon many
shall close their eyes in death and be
habited for the tomb we should now
consider that our life is swiftly
passing away that we are not safe one
moment unless our life is hid with
Christ in God our duty is not to be
looking forward to some special time for
some special work to be done for us but
to go forward in our work of warning the
world for we are to be Witnesses of
Christ to the uttermost part of the
world Martin this message is so
important Christ is in the most holy
place your churches are in the Holy
Place thinking that you can be without
law and just accept the forgiveness and
the justification without the
consequences it's all desolate those
system are desolate your systems have
fallen they have fallen they've become
part of Babylon You' have joined the
ecumenical movement which started in
1844 with the creation of the young
men's Christian Association the first
ecumenical grouping in the entire world
and escalated to the point where you've
even given up on justification and
sanctification according to your
doctrines you have fallen you have
fallen
get out of that
system so Martin what's next is the
second coming of Christ yeah and then
it's too
late Christ looking down the ages he saw
how real Christianity would become
almost
extinct so that his second Advent he
would find a state of society similar to
that which existed before the flood even
the churches would be demoralized and
the Bible would be neglected elected and
desecrated while the Protestant world is
by her attitude making concessions to
Rome we should arous to comprehend the
situation and view the contest before us
in the true bearings Let The Watchmen
now lift up their voice like a trumpet
and give the message which is present
Truth for this time let them know where
we are in prophetic history that the
spirit of true protestantism May awaken
all the world
Mar this is so important and that's so
important that just let me are we busy
trying to appease everyone or get in the
good books or are we bringing the truth
to people we have to bring the
truth because he who testified to these
things yes I'm coming soon amen come
Lord Jesus are we
ready the churches will not follow no
they have become desolate their house is
desolate the same thing that happened in
the first seismic shift when they when
the Jews didn't follow Christ into the
holy has happened to the churches they
refused to follow him into the most holy
they refused to bring themselves into
harmony with God's way God's law they've
chosen the way of Cain yeah
Martin these things are
true and the Lord is coming soon this
this is the last opportunity
particularly with the events taking
place in the world
today for Humanity to make a decision to
separate from Fallen
systems otherwise the same will happen
as happened to the Jews that was just a
type yeah the destruction of Jerusalem
was a type of the great destruction of
the entire world when Jesus comes let's
hope people are ready let's learn from
the history lesson that we that you just
gave us again let's pray thank you
Heavenly
Father we have gone the same route as
ancient
Israel we have neglected your
ministration we have neglected the way
of
righteousness we want the benefits
without the
consequences we want the benefits
without
obedience help us to see these things in
the True Light and to follow
wherever you lead and when that all door
opened and you went into the most holy
that root is still open for every
individual even though it has closed for
the systems and the
churches help us as individuals to
follow into the most holy so that we can
become part of a Remnant that keeps the
Commandments and holds to the testimony
of Jesus I pray in Jesus name name amen
amen
[Music]